es ist offiziell Deutschland steckt in
der Rezession zwei Quartale infolge
schrumpft die Wirtschaft vor allem sie
ahnen es wegen hoher Preise und
energieschock jetzt bräuchte es eine
Regierung die die einen Plan hat die an
einem Strang zieht aber find mal eine
also die Ampel streitet von morgens bis
abends nur noch über Heizungen und unser
Kanzler ja ich weiß gar nicht keine
Ahnung
der hofft dass keiner bei ihm Führung
bestellt
Olaf Scholz hält sich hanseatisch zurück
während seine Koalition für unser aller
Augen verbröselt in der Ampel Humor des
gewaltig der Ton im ampelhof wird immer
schärfer Robert habe immer gereizt da
immer dünnhäutiger also wir haben hier
tatsächlich einen handfesten
koalitionskraft das kann man gar nicht
schön reden man könnte sich fragen warum
gehen die nicht auseinander wenn sie eh
miteinander nicht mehr richtig können
tja da fragen Sie mich was
tja tja Zerrüttung ist für diese Ampel
inzwischen ein viel zu kleines Wort die
Grünen sprechen von Zitat Wortbruch weil
die FDP habecks heizungsgesetz weiter
ausbremst klappt das noch vor der
Sommerpause wird knapp inzwischen geht
das Verhältnis liberale grüne wirklich
schon fast in denen ja SM-Bereich oder
in den SM Bereich der natürlich wenn die
FDP hat noch über 100 Fragen zum Gesetz
und sagt chill mal Robert das können wir
ja zur Not auch noch im Oktober
beschließen und ob das jetzt der Oktober
23 wird mal gucken
inzwischen sieht man es dem armen habe
ich auch an hier vorgestern im Bundestag
sah aus wie einer der sich gerne mal
hauen würde
hier sitze mit seiner Gang und sagt wenn
ich den Linden nachher auf dem Parkplatz
erwische
dem schiebe ich seine 100 Fragen sonst
wo rein du
mit dem Vorziehen des Gesetzes schon auf
2024 hat man sich als Ampel selber unter
Zeitdruck gesetzt deswegen wird das in
einigen Punkten auch so ein bisschen
hingehudelt trotzdem hätten sie es
natürlich schon diese Woche wie geplant
im Parlament diskutieren und verbessern
können denn sie sagt man so schön und
wenn man sagt dann muss man vielleicht
auch sagen oder man kann nicht sagen
eben eben was auffällt bei fast allen
Konflikten schlägt sich der Kanzler auf
die Seite der Liberalen während die
Grünen ganz allein den Volkszorn in
Sachen Heizung abkriegen eine latente
München Stimmung an der die FDP nicht
ganz unbeteiligt war meine immer wieder
technologieoffenheit fordern obwohl die
längst im Gesetzentwurf drin steht ist
wirklich nicht die feine Art wenn man
drüber nachdenkt meine Damen und Herren
es folgt die größte Unverschämtheit des
Jahres und das sage ich obwohl erst mai
ist ich bin gegen jede Form von
Dramatisierung wir haben wichtige
Aufgaben vor uns ich rufe dazu auf
wieder zu einer Sache Debatte
zurückzukehren
da ruft dazu auf ohne rot zu werden was
der sich traut unglaublich neulich hieß
es aus der FDP wir haben noch 101 Fragen
an habe ich
101 warum auch immer ja so so ja die die
101 sind aber nie bei habe ich
angekommen gestern haben sie ihm dann 77
Fragen geschickt darunter fragen wie
welche wissenschaftliche Fundierung
steht hinter der Vorgabe Heizungen
müssten künftig zu 65% mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden
weil 65 weniger ist als 100 vielleicht
das haben wir noch hier Frage 72 ist der
Wendler noch mit Laura zusammen
ja das ist plumpen Zeitschinderei von
denen hier der FDP-Generalsekretär mit
konstruktiver Kritik angesetzt
dieses Gesetz überfordert die Menschen
in unserem Land wirtschaftlich und
finanziell hier sind einfach unfassbar
viele Fehler hier brauchen wir ein neues
Gesetz im Prinzip dieses Gesetz ist
ineffizient schlecht fehlerhaft nicht
hilfreich viele Fehler große Baustelle
enorme Defizite wenn man einfach ein
Gesetz macht das funktioniert
wie wäre es denn in der FDP die mal
konstruktiv mit regiert jetzt fange ich
wirklich an zu spinnen meine Damen und
Herren das wäre ja Science Fiction noch
mal das Gesetz hat Mängel natürlich fakt
ist aber auch spätestens Ende der 20er
Jahre schlägt der höhere CO2-Preis auch
beim Heizen gnadenlos zu und dann ist es
gar nicht mal so klug wenn man vorher
eine Stimmung erzeugt die den
Klimaschutz an sich in Frage stellt
Eigentor vor allem aber wie soll das
Vertrauen jemals zurückkehren in dieser
Regierung das Vertrauen ist doch
zerstört ja natürlich komplett zerstört
meine Damen und Herren
man fragt sich wo ist er hin der Zauber
der dem Ampel Anfang innewohnte bist du
noch damals als das hier durchs Netz
ging
[Musik]
ach ja oder war das schön dieser Groove
diese Euphorie inzwischen bräuchte man
wohl eine andere Tonspur
[Musik]
ja das ist die neue Stimmung und meine
Damen und Herren wir wir müssen uns klar
machen der eigentliche soft der kommt ja
erst noch wenn demnächst für den
Haushalt 24 überall gekürzt wird außer
bei der Bundeswehr dann können die
Grünen doch täglich Steuererhöhungen
fordern
meine Prognose in diesem Frühjahr wird
das nichts mehr mit dem heizungsgesetz
nein am 7 juli also genau vor der
parlamentarischen Sommerpause tritt Olaf
Scholz auf den reichstags-balkon und
sagt wir sind zu herzlich willkommen um
ihnen mitzuteilen dass unser Gebäude
Energiegesetz offiziell tot ist
kurz danach liegen sich wildfremde
Menschen in den Armen was meine was wird
für euch ab morgen anders werden nichts
noch in derselben Nacht singt Christian
Lindner am Brandenburger Tor Eis bin
looking for technologieoffenheit auf dem
Land verbrennt man begeistert
e-autoreifen und dreht die Ölheizung auf
volle Pulle
überall heißt es Mister Harbeck ter down
des Windrad und der dritte Oktober wird
abgeschafft dafür feiern wir ab sofort
am 7 juli den Tag der Deutschen Einheit
[Applaus]
ja
das haben wir jetzt davon
genau
genau das ist die Stimmung die man
wochenlang erzeugt hat als FDP Union und
nicht zu vergessen als Bildzeitung
fragen wir mal nach bei dieser Flagge
sie ist ähm Sprecherin des Verbands der
von der heizungsdebatte völlig
verunsichert im deutschen Eigenheim
Besitzer Frau Flagge sie sind
verunsichert ja jetzt nicht mehr ich war
den ganzen Tag im Keller und habe meine
Ölheizung zertrümmert bevor hier
demnächst der Habeck mit seinem grünen
Rollkommando Geld meine Ölheizung kriegt
ihr nicht die mache ich immer noch
selber kaputt damit rechnen die Schweine
nicht nein wahrscheinlich nicht sie
wissen aber schon auch nach dem jetzigen
Gesetzentwurf dürfte ihre Ölheizung noch
bis zu 2045 weiterlaufen Quatsch die CSU
spricht vom
heizungsverbotsgesetz also werden
Heizung verboten wann hätte die CSU mich
jemals angelogen
und damit eins klar ist ich will keine
Wärmepumpe arschfeuer und vom
Elektroschock kriegt man Gehirn Krebs
also habe ich mir jetzt nur hochmoderne
Gasheizung bestellt die ist Wasserstoff
ready keine Ahnung was das ist aber es
klingt super und ready ja ich fürchte
sind sie leider auf die Versprechung
eines attraktiven trickbetrügers
reingefallen
außerdem sollen fossile Heizungen
weiterhin zugelassen werden die
Wasserstoff oder grüne Gase ready sind
also ich bin sowas von grüne Gase ready
das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen
wenn die erstmal kommen die Grünen Gase
dann drehe ich meine Heizkörper auf
Anschlag und macht alle drei Minuten
Aufguss wie schön ja Tatsache ist leider
der grüne Wasserstoff wird in den
nächsten Jahren gerade so für unsere
Industrie reichen und selbst wenn es
genug gäbe wäre er für dich Verbraucher
deutlich teurer als zum Beispiel die
Wärmepumpe was verdammt aber das macht
nichts ich habe mir nämlich zusätzlich
nur für den Fall der Fälle eine Perle
Teil zum bestellt ah hier die ersten 30
Zentner haben sie mir heute schon
geliefert dass es so ein geiles Zeug
Holz ist die Zukunft bestimmt gut
andererseits sind unsere Wälder ohnehin
schon ziemlich im Eimer da weiß ich
jetzt gar nicht ob das Sonne tolle Idee
ist wenn wir alle Pellets verfolgen ja
was soll ich denn stattdessen machen ne
mehr Pullover kaufen Kniebeugen machen
falls gar keiner was dagegen hat jeden
Tag erzählt mir in der Glotze irgendein
Arschgesicht was Neues zum Heizen und
ich habe doch alles versucht ja wegen
haarwerksgesetz habe ich sogar extra
diesen 82-jährigen Mann geheiratet soll
ich hieß 80 muss die Heizung nicht
tauschen
natürlich aber die wollen die
Altersgrenze senken das heißt ich hätte
vielleicht auch 65-Jährigen haben können
das glaube ich diese Mumie aus dem
Sarkophag gerissen
schatz du wolltest mir doch die Füße mit
der hühneraugensalbe eincremen
dieser Flagge vielen Dank
[Applaus]
dieser Flagge
so meine Damen und Herren
mal
eine ganz andere Frage wie läuft es
eigentlich so mit unseren
russland-sanktionen die EU arbeitet
gerade mit Hochdruck am 11
Sanktionspaket gut die bisherigen Pakete
haben noch nicht so hundertprozentig
ihre Wirkung entfaltet aber das kommt
das kommt bestimmt auch die G7 waren
sich da letztes Wochenende in Japan
total einig die freie Welt angeführt von
Joe Biden er gingen Hiroshima
entschlossen voran und kennt eigentlich
nur einen echten Gegner Treppen
er ist ja unten angekommen die G7 drohen
starten aber auch Firmen die Putin
helfen unsere Sanktion zu gehen Ursula
von der Leyen sagt dasselbe im Namen der
Europäischen Union was ganz ulkig ist
meine Damen und Herren weil ja auch
Produkte aus Europa immer noch in
Russland landen massenhaft nur halt über
Drittstaaten sogar russisches Öl kommt
nach wie vor bei uns in Europa an
verkleidet als Benzin aus Indien sie
merken Globalisierung und Sanktion das
geht nicht so richtig gut zusammen wobei
theoretisch ist sanktionsumgebung
natürlich illegal
das ist jetzt schon strafbewährt und
würde sofern der Nachweis gelingt dass
es sich um eine bewusste Entscheidung
handelt auch strafrechtlich relevant
sein beziehungsweise verfolgt werden
vor allem gehört es sich nicht
[Applaus]
es gehört sich nicht ja gut klingt mir
fast ein Tick zu niedlich muss ich sagen
kurz zur Einordnung wenn man nur mal ist
Beispiel in einem Fahrstuhl nach einem
Red Bull und einer Tankstellen Bulette
aufstößt das gehört sich nicht meine
Damen und Herren
Halbleiter liefern die dann in
russischen Marschflugkörpern landen
dafür kommt man in die Hölle
gehört sich nicht Hölle
Starten aus der russischen Nachbarschaft
kaufen plötzlich ohne Ende
Waschmaschinen und Kühlschränke zum
Beispiel aus Deutschland und schicken
die inklusive begehrter Mikrochips an
Putin unsere Exporteinnahmen mit
Kirgisistan zum Beispiel sind zuletzt um
über 1000% gewachsen auch armenien hat
sich scheinbar spontan verliebt in
unsere deutschen Elektrogeräte ja weil
die so wahnsinnig gut sind
weil die so gut sind klar wenn man Tick
zu lange drüber nachdenkt sind manche
Zahlen schon irgendwie verdächtig
2021 exportierte die Türkei Halbleiter
und elektronische Schaltkreise im Wert
von rund 300.000 Dollar nach Russland im
vergangenen Jahr stieg der Wert auf über
86 Millionen ja das sind wahrscheinlich
ganz normale Schwankungen würde ich
sagen ja bringt übrigens nichts darüber
nachzudenken denn Sanktionen gegen die
Türkei gehen eh nicht weil NATO Mitglied
da machst du nichts jede Zeit hat halt
ihre friedensbotschaften wissen Sie noch
früher hieß es Schwerter zu flugschaden
und heute eben
Waschmaschinen zu Kampfjets ja
Waffensysteme gepinnt mit deutschen
Haushaltsgeräten gut das erkennt
natürlich auch warum die Militärparade
neulich durch Moskau so anders
ausgesehen hat hier zum Beispiel bestaun
Putin das ruhmreiche siebte
rasenroboterbataillon
ja das neueste Sanktionspaket der EU ist
übrigens im Gegensatz zu unseren
Mikrochips leider noch nicht in Moskau
angekommen warum weil Ungarn bremst und
blockiert und weil EU-Beschlüsse zur
Außenpolitik immer einstimmig fallen
müssen ist blöd
eventuell doch ein europäischer
Konstruktionsfehler höchste Zeit also
für unangenehme Wahrheiten im
Europaparlament
Gernot Hassknecht hält eine Rede in
Straßburg
heute bonjour
very much
gab es immerhin noch ein europäisches
Projekt an das ich geglaubt habe den ESC
aber von wegen ja der deutsche Song war
wie immer scheiße trotzdem Top 20 sollte
ja wohl mal drin sein für die Kohle die
wir hier reinballern egal anderes Thema
Russland Sanktionen Überraschung die
wirken nicht laut IBF wird die russische
Wirtschaft spürbar wachsen
ja weil die Chinesen und Kinder unsere
Sanktionen unterlaufen am Arsch das
Problem sitzt doch hier mitten unter
euch und hat Kopfhörer auf da sitzt er
der Gulasch mit Ohren Orban hat gerade
erst neue Verträge mit Moskau
abgeschlossen und kauft jetzt noch mehr
Gas bei Putin und was macht ihr ein
dummes Gesicht ja genau das Gesicht
meine ich grüß Dich Uschi Ungarn ist
EU-Land um Himmels willen was muss man
denn noch machen um hieraus zu fliegen
stimmt man kann ja gar nicht rausfliegen
Viktor Orban ist ganz offensichtlich
Putins Mann in der EU gibt's außerhalb
von Russland und Ungarn eigentlich noch
irgendeinen Vollidioten der orban-fan
ist
keine weiteren Fragen Vorschlag
versuch's doch mal mit
konsequenten Sanktionen Belgien
importiert weiter russische Diamanten
Finnland und Frankreich russische
atombrennstäbe so macht das alles null
Sinn
ja genau schreibt das mit macron deine
Frau kontrolliert nachher die
Hausaufgaben Fenster will sagen ganz
viele hier im Saal machen Putin jeden
Tag reicher und füllen seine Kriegskasse
am besten sparen wir uns das ganze
gehorchen und stellen morgen einen
Mitgliedsantrag bei der Russischen
Föderation danke schön und jetzt die
neue eu-hymne
[Musik]
gernotasknecht hielt eine Regel in
Straßburg
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten